is belief in Allah and the messengers
the angels and the final day and the
Holy Scriptures to believe in destiny
that good and bad both come from him and
there's mama like I'm like some you know
al hamdulillah salam-o-alaikum which
means peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Deen show we have
a great topic for you today something
very interesting Muslim you know the
Muslim is one who surrenders and submits
to one God worshiping of him alone
without any associates and you know what
atheist is a the--is something that's
weird just something that's way out
there but you got some people that are
weird in their atheist but today we have
someone who was a former Muslim atheist
that I catch you by surprise well it
kind of caught me also but we're gonna
be back with our next guests and we're
gonna help clear this up what do we mean
is that possible a Muslim atheist when
we come back on the deen she'll be right
back
how mad is his messenger Allah
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamu alaikum salam wa tuula how are
you very good come to the gnomon Alikhan
yes how are you brother very good very
good very excited to have you on the
show thank you very excited to be here
all right you got your this is a gift
for you you got to be show cub you could
take home with fantastic something to
give my kids candy and yeah and you want
to talk a little bit about the wonderful
work that you're doing but before then
we're gonna talk about what I just had
mentioned Muslim atheist is that even
possible I don't think so but it kind of
happens in the closet sense oh what he
was referring to and what you were
referring to is a little bit of an
internal struggle that I went through
when I was at the age of about junior
high and you know junior in high school
senior in high school basically it was a
loss of religion so when I came to the
United States this was about in ninth
grade you know I came it was a culture
shock and a lot of the values that I was
raised with were all being questioned
all at the same time and it was really
nobody that I could talk to or verify my
own beliefs with and eventually what
happens in the school environment is you
make friends you know based on proximity
based on common interest whoever is
accessible to you so most of my friends
were people that were either polytheists
or they were actually atheists would
mean polytheists of some Hindus some
Buddhists those are they worship
multiple guys they worship multiple gods
and actually each of them had their own
different God among themselves okay
that's a big no-no me yeah and a good
number of them very smart people were
actually atheists so you know falling
into that crowd and just not being
around any Muslims generally I kind of
had hid these thoughts and these
confusions from my family because I knew
how table they can be and you can't
really share these kinds of confuse
at home so I kind of learned to live
with them
and over time what that ended up
happening was I had a really a good
bunch of really messed up friends and my
company became such that was I actually
had a hatred almost for the concept of
God I was i I thought it was a
detestable concept and I'd reached that
point and Subhan Allah it is by the
mercy of allah subhana wa ta'ala that
allah opened many many many doors one
after another for me that I couldn't
have opened for myself that led me back
to Iman that led me back to my faith and
back to my convert all here something
you said from my Arabic word you're
gonna have to define ok the Deen show we
got a lot of non-muslims listen and you
said I think I caught two of them there
he said Iman and back it up ok not as
conviction and faith yeah so I said I
was led back to my conviction back to
Iman that's the the Arabic term for
faith and it's actually related to the
term Eman which is peace so actually we
Muslims believe that your faith is
actually a source of peace for you and
others on the other hand the other term
I used was alhamdulillah which is my
expression and all Muslims expressions
of expressing our faith our gratitude
and our appreciation of what Allah does
for us so and you said Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala Allah subhana WA Ta'ala so hanno
Matata I mean Allah is his name his
glorified name Subhanahu that part of it
means how perfect he is it's a
translation of subhana WA Ta'ala means
how elevated how high he is meaning we
aren't to say something that is
belittling the status of a lot ok they
can put their Arabic books away now okay
very cool so will your parents were they
devout Muslims were they practicing were
they not practicing they were semi
practicing Muslims I wouldn't call them
strictly religious yeah but they there
was some practice in are who my dad was
fairly regular with his prayers we
didn't really have religion far beyond
that at the home but really religion and
and belief became a thing that I
associated more with my friends than I
did with the family over time and
actually it reminds me of a famous
statement of the Prophet sallallahu
wasallam the Arabic goes on Adina colony
he
yello-ha documen you holla what that
means is a person depends on the
religion of their friend and watch out
who you make friends with raha do come
on you clod and those words actually
ring a really strong bell with me in my
life
and have a great impact on the advice I
give to other youth because no matter
how smart you think you are or how on
top of your faith you are it's just a
matter of having messed up friends and
your you could just gonna get just as
messed up if not worse than you are now
depending on that so so I was at that
stage in my life and there were two
kinds of doors that Allah opened for me
one of them was intellectual and that
was a little later but the other one was
social Allah opened a door for me in
college where I met a person that I
would probably never have associated
imagine being friends with and I kind of
you would call it by chance ran into him
and you know just sitting in the hallway
just hanging out I see this this guy
come up and just post a flyer on the you
know the college billboard where all
these clubs post their flyers yeah and
it says Muslim Student Association right
like what is this Muslim store they must
really party because they might they
might get all the Muslims for all the
different countries yeah and jam
together that's what I thought it was
right now so so I go to him and I start
talking to music yeah it's a lot of fun
you got to come and you know it's gonna
be great
so all the other clubs that I was part
of I skipped out on and I went to this
supposedly great party club that I was
going to join and so I go there and
there's no one in the room except that
one guy that had put up the fliers and
there's a box of pizza and he's kind of
waiting for folks to show up so when i
walked in i felt kind of awkward like i
don't know what i'm if I really belong
here or not so I was trying to leave but
he kind of reeled me in we just start
talking a little pizza become a little
friend yeah you know a growing
acquaintance and what ended up happening
was I used to take the subway home I
used to go to college in New York City
so I used to take the subway home and he
would just instead give me a ride home
and he had a nice ride too so it was
kind of it was nice of him and we'd stop
by grab a bite you know here and there
just hang out and this became almost
every two three days I just go
hang out with him no Aslam no religion
nothing yeah it was just he was just a
friend that's all and after a few months
of just givin me a ride and hanging out
being great company giving good advice
on what professors to take classes
because he was a senior in college I was
the freshman yeah you know he says to me
you know one time we're stuck in traffic
on the Li I still remember he's like
we're getting late to get home you mind
if I stop and pray about it and it just
so happened that the prayer times never
conflicted in my commute home with him
yeah now that's the that's the fourth
prayer of the day that's the fourth way
this is the evening prayer now what that
was you know from your parent I did back
then but I hadn't at that point it must
have been at least six years that I had
prayed at all I mean Friday eat whatever
I hadn't prayed anything at all yeah so
you know he says you mind if I stop now
is it okay yeah why not
so he goes and I kind of inexplicably
feel the urge to pray with him I kind of
felt bad so I go and I make all the when
I'm I pray with him at them at this
Masjid in Queens and it kind of I felt
something you know that I hadn't felt in
a very long time just a kind of peace
yeah I tried to bury it for Ohio but
then hamdullah
again praising glory and thanks be to
Allah and appreciation only becoming of
Allah that he he gave me that consistent
company and through him I got to meet a
lot of wonderful people but he just kind
of connected me to just some amazing
people one of which is Imam sahaja watch
you know a great hero of our community
he's just some really mesmerizing
individuals and he acquainted me with
other young Muslims that were very
active in their community just doing
things that matter you know and they
were they were trying to make the world
a better place kind of thing and it made
me think like all these people have such
a sense of sense of purpose what are
they getting it from but you didn't
really have a purpose done no I just I
mean like what were some of your
ambitions I mean you obviously almost
someone is striving for the hereafter to
please his Lord to become the best human
being he could possibly be
what were your ambitions I mean before I
turn to Dean yeah I don't think I really
had much of an ambition I was I mean if
you ask the average college youth what
are your goals in life they'll say I
don't know I'll think about it later
that kind of thing you know they just
want to take one day at a time just live
it up live for the day sort of thing you
know you know you can't really think me
even beyond your immediate semester only
when you get like to junior year senior
year in college you start thinking about
your career or like what major you want
to do and things like that so even in
the worldly sense young people tend to
be very and if we stop myself I was very
empathetic like I didn't really care it
was kind of like you know let it just
all slide yeah you know but anyway
because he connected me to these
individuals yeah one of the things he
did for me was he introduced me to this
program that was going on in the Muslim
Center in Flushing which was basically
in in Ramadan you know Muslims get
together and congregate in high numbers
and the long thought i we have prayers
go on at night but what this program was
special in that there was thought out we
prayer and then it was coupled with a
lecture series of the entire Quran
beginning to end in 30 day there in 30
nights so you pray and listen to the
recitation of Quran but at the same time
you get to hear the entire thing
explained in brief translation and brief
extras very key now knowing what is
being said right and I had never I mean
before this I had tried reading the
translation of the Quran and was maybe
the use of Riley yeah I found the
English may Allah reward him for his
work but I found the translation
biblical and at that point as you know
late high school early college I was
like okay I don't know I don't get this
so I you and put it aside but then what
ends up happening is I I listen to this
live presentation of the Quran beginning
- and it's being presented as a dialogue
and what this is probably the first time
in my life I came to realize for myself
that the Quran is actually a dialogue
and Allah is talking to me right the
Lord of the Worlds is directly engaged
in conversation with me you know when
you read a book it's different but when
you hear a conversation it has a
different effect even now like if you
read an article of a great speech or a
transcript of a great speech it won't
move you like that but if you were at
that speech and it was a the order knew
what he was doing
that would really it would rattle you
right so this ends up happening
I'm just mystified by this book and I
mean I spent those 30 days I mean the
thing was long it was like one just a
thirtieth of the Quran every night in
explanation with the prayer so this was
like an 8 p.m. to like a 2 a.m. 3 a.m.
endeavor so you know I did this for the
entire month and this was like my first
exposure seriously to Islam after my
childhood schooling I was being exposed
to the entire book in one shot with one
teacher with one one presenter yeah
and you know at that point I had started
listening to other lectures and talks by
different speakers and presenters on
various topics just gaining curiosity in
Islam but of all the things I had heard
I had never heard something so moving as
the Quran presented itself let it speak
for itself
so at the end of the 30 days I went to
the the presenter his name is dr. obtuse
Emmy
yeah and I said to him a lot of people
are doing things for Islam but I want to
do what you do how do you do what you do
I want I want to be what you're doing
now hold that point we're going to get
to that and tell us before you went and
you had this experience being an atheist
did you check into any other religions I
know what is amiss chant did you like
kind of I talk a lot of philosophy
courses in call it Lhasa fee yeah and it
was actually more of a turn-off than
anything else
I was very dismayed first of all by
other religious theologies because the
the inconsistency wasn't even something
you find later on it's light on the
front page yeah you know it's it's you
don't have to go further to you saw it
on the front page it was like just move
on you know and it kind of it generally
it turns you off from religion in
general because you figure okay this
religion doesn't make any sense by
assumption all religions must be this
nonsensical okay right and this is what
a lot of people do actually they find
one religion that doesn't make sense so
they make that assumption for all
religions they say oh they're all
man-made or they're all this way or that
way I did study some Islamic philosophy
in college but it was presented by a
Zoroastrian professor most probably an
agnostic
so he presented it in a very strange
kind of way so I didn't really see
anything to it but though in my mind I
was already the idea of
aslam being more than just a spiritual
thing being an intellectual thing was
fermenting it was in my in the back of
my mind why do you think this is very
important because I'm sure there are
people closeted Muslims or people who
are born into families that are Muslims
but you have to make a subconscious
decision to submit yourself yeah so it's
not by default now you just got it made
I got two things to say about that yeah
atheism uh-huh is actually a conscious
decision it doesn't occur naturally not
at all no you mean you made a good point
we spoke earlier that when the person is
up and hit some turbulence in a plane
yeah and this is what Allah says in the
Quran turns off his atheism it just for
this few seconds oh god save me yeah you
know or they say there's no atheists in
foxholes yeah yes so now you have so
that's one thing about atheism the other
thing about atheism is it's actually not
rooted at least from all the atheist
friends that I had it's not rude it it's
something intellectual that's the facade
it's actually rooted in something
psychological these people are either
traumatized or they had a really bad
experience in life or they've seen
something that they were really
emotionally disturbed by they decided to
blame God for it right and as part of
their reaction against God let you know
what what's the biggest offence I can do
he doesn't even exist right yeah so it
starts with questioning God and then
moves on to the ultimate you know
supposedly offense against God I don't
even think he exists so this would be
something like I said earlier this is
weird isn't it weird
it is weird it is it's to me it's
actually a disorder yeah and these are
disturbed people they're I mean if
you've come to the conclusion of atheism
first of all you've made an absolute
statement about something you have no
idea right the agnosticism from the
atheist the agnostics says I don't know
maybe there is a god maybe there isn't I
don't have a way of knowing in that at
least there is some acknowledgement of
humility that I don't know right at
least there's that much and we can work
with that somewhat but the Atheist would
explicit like absolute you know
certainty says there's absolutely no way
there's a God and he's absolutely
denying something that he can't even see
your judge so it is basically than he's
saying
he or she if I can't see it it doesn't
exist right if I can't see it it doesn't
exist this is the the essence of their
intellectual problem right they say that
it you know the only thing that can be
judged is empirical evidence meaning the
five senses science this is what exists
that's it
but even then who decided what the five
senses are who decided this is the only
sources of knowledge etc no answer where
does love come from where does hate come
from where does fear come emotions where
does hope and aspiration come from oh
they're just chemicals in our body so
they want to reduce the human being even
to just a sophisticated animal and
because they've done that you'll find
these different kinds of weird crimes in
our society that you never found in
history like the the craziest kinds of
things sickest kinds of things people do
when they have no sense of consequence
they have no purpose left in life
there's no one watching over them
there's there's no one they have to
answer for if they can get away with it
they'll get away with it and that's the
society in which you get these heinous
crimes like we're not even talking about
murder and stealing and you know these
are your average Joe crimes we're
talking about just sick disturbing I
don't understand why anybody would do
this kind of thing yeah kinds of crimes
that's a byproduct of atheism
you've given you've taken hope and
purpose away from people and they're
Allah calls them animals or even worse
this is the even worse part so tell us
maybe there's somebody here that you
know what he can relate to what you have
to say he might be somehow covering up
that belief and the one God and and
something that's really rational and he
doesn't want to be weird anymore how
would you invite him and give him some
just some some basic Dawa or inviting
him and to you know something as natural
I could I could speak from my personal
experience yes on the one hand you have
to have sincerity and nobody can put
that in you you have to you have to beg
for it if you if you kind of even say if
there's a God out there
I need sincerity I sincerely seek you
out I'm sincerely in search and ask for
the guidance ask for the guidance the
other thing is beyond that leap beyond
that seeking of guidance
what brought me to absolute conviction
after my background in philosophy and
like you know this atheist phase and
rationalizing everything that exposure
to Quran that I had wasn't just a
spiritual experience it was actually a
very powerful intellectual experience
for me like every major argument I had
against religion or God was answered
without me having to ask the question I
was just listening to Quran carefully
and it was it was like there were a lot
of knots in my mind and it was just
undoing them one after another the Quran
answered all the questions
yeah the doubts that you had all the
doubts that I I think that's one problem
people have they might be born in a
family of atheists or some other
religion and they use their intellect
and they see that this stuff don't make
sense it's weird yeah
and now they paint everything with the
same brush that Islam is not that Islam
is not that but I tell you one or
advantage that I did have is that I had
somebody who had given their life to
studying the Quran yeah simplifying it
for me and this is a big deal
like even the average person if they
read the Quran for themselves right they
will get guidance I know people that
went to the public library read the
Quran and became Muslim yeah right and
this does happen but there's also the
chance of you reading the Quran and
because there are so many passages that
are contextual and you know if you don't
understand that context and that entire
scenario you're not really going to get
with it what it's saying so you might
even read the Quran and come out a
little confused you might you might say
I wonder what that's about
yeah or why is this here why is that
there and this is what actually some
evangelicals like to pick on right yeah
they'll take a bitter piece of the
biddin piece of the Quran and they'll
take it out entirely out of context out
of historical and textual context and
say aha look at what your book says
right but on the look at the flipside
just on quoting out of context the Quran
says whele little mousseline and Athena
whom Ancelotti him Sehun there's two two
verses if you will I like the word IR
better rather than verse because it's
proprietary to the Quran it says
ultimate destruction is to fall upon
those who pray that's the first verse
those who in regards to their prayers
are heedless they're careless in regards
to their prayer now if you just take the
first verse
and say ultimate destruction is for
those who pray and you forget the rest
of the context you get this crazy
conclusion that the Quran is saying
people who pray are destroyed but it's
talking about people who don't care
about their prayer who make a mockery of
prayer right so context is really
important and that's the benefit I had
with this teacher the entire Quran
presented in context and it really I
without doing any formal training in
Islamic studies this was my first
exposure formally formally in Islamic
studies or in a faraway what this did
for me was basically solidified this is
what I have to say if I want to confirm
my conviction I have to become a student
of this book so over the last nine years
or so I stole going on first I became a
student of the Arabic language then I
became a student of this it's a specific
science and Islamic studies called the
science of tafseer yeah which is the
science of studying the explanation of
the Quran the scholarly explanation of
the Quran in connection with the other
sacred literature in asonde asonde ah so
the Quran and some that come together
and you properly understand though there
other components too so I became a
student of this area specifically
because it brought me to the Dean it
brought me to my conviction it pulled me
out of my darkness into whatever light
Allah had brought me to so I stuck to
this topic I you know there are other
topics in Islam um you could study fifth
you can study al-qaeda you can study
many different topics I studied them so
much as they apply to my personal life
but as an endeavor I stuck to two things
Arabic classical Arabic studies and
Quran related studies and within that
journey what happened was in the first
couple of years I was looking at the
message of the Quran understanding
comprehensively its lessons its
teachings it's it's overwhelming
overlying themes right so like the
bigger picture of the Quran but then
over the last I think about four years
now my focus changed to what makes the
Quran miraculous so the first part was
the message of the Quran and the latter
part became the miracle of the Quran and
when I was first introduced to that
topic even though I had been the student
of the Quran for a few years already
when I first got introduced to the topic
formally on the Morocco
power of the Quran I felt like I hadn't
been studying Quran before like I
thought I knew what it's saying but I
never saw it in this light so what Allah
opened for me subhana WA Ta'ala may his
name be glorified and he deserves the
attribution of all perfection what he
opened for me was a door to appreciate
this Quran in an entirely new light now
to sum this up basically most people
their experience with the Quran even if
you're like devout Muslims right Muslims
are not your experience with the Quran
is just as a message as a religious
message you don't necessarily see it as
a miracle like I mean imagine standing
next to Moses Mossad is a time when the
waters parting
right that kind of a miracle we don't
associate reading the Quran with that
but if you engage in this study it takes
a little bit of an effort but if you
engage in this study you can begin to
experience that miracle we're almost out
of time tell us for a couple of avenues
a person that is a Muslim but he has
doubts and he is kind of confused you
know parents going through the rituals
he's just going through the rituals or
in the back like a robot what advice to
him and you got the Atheist attention
also he wants to know what's up with
this miracle you're saying about the
Quran yeah give us we're gonna do such a
show talking about the miracles of the
Quran and how we will give proof and
evidences that it is indeed not a
man-made book but a revelation from the
Creator give us some some advice for the
Muslim and who was in your situation and
the atheist my advice to Muslims my
first bit of advice company you need
company that is serious about learning
the religion that is supportive you you
may find that company on campus you may
find it at your local masjid it might be
the Imam of your mustard but find
someone in your community that you look
up to that you can spend more and more
and more time with this is the key in
the end like that hadith says and it was
true from he our religion in it does
depend on our company you know you have
good company your religion will benefit
you will grow intellectually you'll have
people that can address your concerns
and if they themselves can address your
concerns if they're sincere they
point you to the right resources and
people that can address your concerns
and this is what happened with me I had
a certain kind of question and I got
pointed to a certain kind of specialist
in that area that would help me with
that question so this would be my
probably primary advice yeah change of
company
you know don't waste your life away if
you're what if your life looks the same
every day you just wake up do some
school or whatever hang out and then you
know party and go to sleep and that's
your your everyday so your entire life
looks like one day it's it's like
there's no there's no nothing new in
your life is one item time it's just
wasting you giving your life away don't
assume that you have all the time in the
world our time our clock is not in our
hands so feel a sense of urgency find
good company and sincerely begin to look
into the religion for proper proper
guidance also recently because of the
advent of programs like Al Maghrib
Institute where and others that are you
know they're doing Islamic Studies kinds
of programs find those programs out and
take classes tell us also the the Baena
Albania Institute you the head yeah but
you know with them of you yeah it's now
in collaboration with the Muslim
alhamdulillah
the idea behind Vienna was to facilitate
Arabic studies for Muslims and general
audiences across the United States the
reason I started it was I had to go
through a very difficult journey in
learning and I didn't want other people
to go through that journey so I as a
student developed a program along with
some colleagues that the idea behind
which was to get the message out there
that Arabic is easy to learn actually I
would argue miraculously easy to learn
despite it being such a complex language
if only you come to it with the
intention that you want to learn Quran
there's actually divine intervention and
how easy it becomes for you so with that
intention we started alhamdulillah it's
been over 72 communities thus far across
the country nearly 8,000 students they
consider they can visit you at which
you're you have yeah it's 'bageena calm
Dina calm vay why I and aah calm you can
see our website our programs that are
being offered to have actually
one minute left the Atheist you've got
the tell him something yes talk to him
okay so to my fellow human a theist my
sincere advice if you even fathom the
possibility that there is a creator if
that possibility even like the slightest
ounce of that possibility exists in your
mind consider the consequences of not
reflecting on that possibility if you
are willing to take a chance on your
life and your your-your-your well-being
to guarantee yourself there's no
hereafter at all
nobody's looking after me nobody's going
to question what I did and you want to
just live your life if you're willing to
take that risk
go ahead God is not going to force you
to accept him but if there's that my new
idea in your head that you know if it's
even possible that he exists and that he
is he has given me guidance and he has
expectations of me and I have
deliberately chosen not even to think
about it then the consequences are on
you on and not on him so with that that
slightest possibility be sincere to that
possibility for your own sake not for
anybody elses and inquire into into the
divine look and really ask for guidance
in the end because as Muslims we know
it's not our intellect that reaches God
or that we guide ourselves our intellect
only goes so far
and then there's divine intervention
something opens up in your chest so you
feel a peace you feel an ease and you'll
you'll be able to find that that faith
but it is part of it is an intellectual
journey and part of it is a spiritual
journey I know for an atheist
acknowledging anything spiritual is very
very difficult but humble yourself
you've had spiritual experiences no
matter who you are you've had a
spiritual experience acknowledged that
you there's an entity inside you that
isn't entirely rational or logical we're
not purely lot we're not machines we're
human beings we have emotions we have
spirituality so let that humanist of you
seek out the lord of the worlds thank
you very much we're out of time and
we're gonna inshallah do some more shows
with you quite well they look forward to
seeing more of my brother no man Ali
Khan from the Baena Institute at
jazakallah Haider
I love Ward you for being with us today
yeah thank you some benefit for your
story and I'd like to thank you and all
of you that are out there
supporting a Dean show coming back every
week to see a new show and all those
people out there who are watching us
trying to learn about Islam which is the
fastest growing way of life out there
it's not something weird don't be weird
you don't want to be somebody standing
out like an atheist year's small
minority you got what the heard what the
brother had to say
God wants to guide you he's out there
but do you want to be guided start with
that first step ask him to guide you and
then use the tools that he's given you
and the truth shall be made clear we
hope to see you again next time on the
Deen show until then assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you doesn't see what
everyone's talking about who if you find
one contradiction it can't be from God
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for spring guidance or I will never
give up spreading this message hope
there you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now the reality of
life usually doesn't sink in until
tragedy commas you get a few bad people
the media grabs ahold of that and spends
it the way they want to if you say that
you do not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his none you cannot
be a muslim a that ended our faith to
eat scone italy everybody sleeping i
arise and ask a lot of thinking me Omar
you see all our you know all the sins I
do I turn to you to forgive my sin
tomorrow I'm you seem for slave you know
my love alone I'm the one runs away all
the guy me